intersección tan importante de las
relaciones transatlánticas hemos oído
del presidente bailar hemos oído de los
líderes europeos y espero recibirlos en
nuestra cumbre de la otan más adelante
este año para establecer una nueva
agenda transatlántica en los últimos
años hemos visto diferencias entre
europa y norteamérica hay varias
inquietudes sobre la fortaleza de
nuestra alianza en ambos lados del
atlántico y visiones que compiten en la
vida per sentida estas tácticas ahora
tenemos una oportunidad histórica de
construir una alianza más fuerte de
recuperar la confianza y de reforzar
nuestra unidad europa y norteamérica
trabajando juntos en la otan en
solidaridad estratégica
ya que enfrentamos grandes desafíos el
crecimiento de china los ciberataques
sofisticados cambio climático el
comportamiento desestabilizador de rusia
y la amenaza del terrorismo continuada
ningún país en ningún continente pueden
superar estos solos al contrario debemos
hacer más juntos y debemos demostrar
nuestro compromiso a la solidaridad
atrasa crítica no solamente en palabras
sino en actos por eso es que bajo la
bandera de otan 2030 estamos trabajando
en una ambiciosa agenda para el futuro
de nuestra alianza en primer lugar
debemos reforzar nuestra unidad esa
unidad se deriva de la promesa que hemos
hecho de promete de protegernos el uno
al otro
debemos fortalecer nuestros compromisos
para lograr la defensa colectiva
encontrar la defensa de nuestros
territorios unidos esto incentivar a los
salientes a los aliados a tener
capacidades a desarrollarlas y seguir
contribuyendo a manejar las cargas la
otan es la única plataforma que reúne a
europa
a eeuu cada día los aliados deben estar
comprometidos para consultar cada tema
que afecta nuestra seguridad debemos
actualizar el concepto estratégico de la
otan para desarrollar un curso común de
aquí en adelante y reafirmar las bases
fundamentales de nuestra confianza en
segundo lugar
debemos ampliar nuestro acercamiento a
la seguridad nuestros potenciales
adversarios utilizan todas las
herramientas a su disposición militares
políticas y económicas para desafiar a
nuestras instituciones debilitar a
nuestras sociedades y minar nuestra
seguridad
por supuesto para mantener a nuestra
gente a salvo necesitamos un ejército
fuerte pero también necesitamos una
sociedad fuerte unas sociedades fuertes
como primera línea de defensa
necesitamos un acercamiento más
coordinado más amplio respecto a la
resiliencia con metas claras nacionales
de comunicaciones incluyendo 5g y cables
subacuáticos y suministros de energía y
una asesoría conjunta de toda
vulnerabilidad también debemos invertir
para mantener nuestra ventaja
tecnológica y compartir y hacer que
nuestras fuerzas sean impermeables y
desarrollar usos éticos de estas nuevas
tecnologías
y ampliar nuestra aproximación a la
seguridad también significa dirigirnos
al impacto de seguridad del cambio
climático
creo que la otan debe establecer el
mejor estándar sobre cómo reducir
emisiones
como reducir desde el ejército se
contribuye a llegar a la meta cero de
misiones en tercer lugar europa y
norteamérica deben defender las reglas
internacionales y sus espacios esto ha
sido desafiado por poderes autoritarios
china y rúsia están intentando
reescribir las reglas para beneficiar
sus propios intereses el crecimiento de
china es un tema definitivo para la
comunidad transatlántica con
consecuencias potenciales para nuestra
seguridad nuestra prosperidad de nuestro
estilo de vida
por eso es que la otan debe profundizar
en sus relaciones con alianzas cercanas
como usted y japón y forjar nuevas
alianzas alrededor del mundo solamente
con acciones concertadas se puede animar
a otros se puede impulsar a otros a
seguir las reglas defender nuestras
reglas defender nuestras reglas inicia
con defender nuestros valores en casa
tenemos comprometernos de nuevo con
nuestros valores fortalecer nuestras
democracias y proteger nuestras
instituciones porque al final es
esto es lo que nos hace quienes somos
por más de 70 años la otan ha asegurado
la parte necesaria del atlántico a pesar
de los desafíos que siguen evolucionando
y los vientos políticos se cambian
nuestra relación transatlántica no
solamente ha perdurado sino que ha
florecido este es un testamento a los
valores que compartimos ya la otan la
incorporación de nuestro lazo
transatlántico
y todos tenemos una responsabilidad de
hacer que ese momento valga la pena
fortalecer este lazo y mantener a europa
y en norteamérica unidos en solidaridad
estratégica muchas gracias